[Music]
when you look at the historical
experience of african-americans in the
United States you have to start with the
experience of slavery and the vestiges
of slavery in terms of the Trump the
trauma associated with it and I think
that you know blacks continue to
experience trauma in certain ways and
certainly with respect to those who live
in urban communities that are sort of
infested with drugs or that are
particularly violent those are traumatic
situations that they experience on a
daily basis certainly as we seen in in
recent events interactions with the
police can be again particularly
traumatic so when you talk about mental
illness and a black community I think
you have to begin with the experience of
trauma and how trauma continues to
abound in and their experiences and in
their daily lives I think that what
happens for a lot of individuals is that
they suffer in silence with respect to
having a mental illness and so what I
mean by that in the greater society
there's certainly a lot of stigma
associated with mental illness it's sort
of antithetical to the American ethic
which is to you know be strong and
courageous to pull yourself up by the
bootstraps to weather the storm etc I
think the second part of that you know
point is what's happening at the
community level or the society level and
I think what happens is that within the
black community I think that again you
know that ethic about what it means to
be strong and courageous is particularly
pronounced because
of trying to you know combat those
forces like discrimination or racism and
you know it's just adds to the burden of
you know sort of what it means to
survive and so then the person who's
struggling with the mental illness is
perhaps not embraced or you know warmly
accepted because of their struggles you
know I remember as a young person
growing up I used to hear about the
person who was quote-unquote sent down
south I used to wonder what that meant
and it wasn't until I got older that I
became you know more knowledgeable of
the fact that a person that person was
struggling with a mental illness or
perhaps substance abuse from a
historical perspective there's been a
lot of emphasis in the black community
particularly in fact families on keeping
your problems close to the vest in the
home you don't share what's going on
with outsiders no one can treat you as
best as your family can you bring all
your burdens and your problems to your
family and if you do take it any to any
entity outside of your family it's the
black church the church is really
important in the black community make no
mistake about it it's a source of you
know sort of salvation and and healing
and there's their whole collective
support from you know you get from your
fellow churchgoers and that sort of
thing but I think also what has
historically happened is died the church
has been defined as the place to you
know sort of relieve your symptoms or to
address your burdens and so it stops
there and what I think needs to happen
is that first of all I think pastors and
lay ministers can be more trained in the
signs and presentations of mental
illness but I think that the church
could be sort of a triage unit if you
will such that it identifies those who
have needs and it's that sort of first
step and the your sort of entree into
care but it shouldn't stop there I
believe that culturally competent care
is critical to everything if patients
perceive that providers are inauthentic
and do not care about their unique
circumstances then they're likely to be
turned off at a baseline providers
should understand their the history of
their neighborhoods for example or the
history of the experience of of
african-americans and Latinos such that
they can put the clinical presentation
into context and understand what unique
factors are in play with respect to the
clinical presentation and how that
person is seeking to you know survive
and live in the world as an African
American or Latino and so I think that
it's the onus is on the provider to
understand that context and to
understand what it means for that person
to live and
context